Now you've seen IP addresses before
like 50.116.54.191 or 8.8.8.8.
An IP address is used to designate a
particular destination on the Internet,
typically a particular machine.
And every message that travels
over the Internet, a web request,
an email, a ping, or what have you.
Is split into packets, and every one
of these packets has the IP address of
the machine it came from and
where it's going to.
Now a point about terminology, in this
lesson in the rest of the course,
you'll hear me talk about hosts a lot.
A host is just a machine
on the Internet,
particularly one that
might host services.
You'll also hear me talk about
the endpoints of a connection,
those are just the two machines or
programs that are communicating
over that connection.
Okay, let's get started.
First off,
let's take another look at something
you've definitely seen before, Ping.